take off my boots oh my god my boot not
my foot grow up fast
just like 20 pounds overweight Kylie
Jenner just trolls her sisters in the
most epic way possible this is the
plaintiff your people this is not the
land
this is Glendale with a montage of
tik-tok videos and it's awesome
on Monday the beauty mogul shared this
clip with her bestie Stassi re-enacting
some iconic Keeping Up with the
Kardashians moments yeah like the time
Kim was still with Kris Humphries and
went on vacation where tropical with the
fam and totally lost it when she lost
her diamond earring like I said lost it
[Music]
classic nailed it and they nailed all of
these moments to I'll be there for you
90% of the time you're a version of 90
anyways is just unacceptable your issue
is but sometimes I know I'm going to
tell you what your issue is to be
related to you you're lucky that I'm
gracing you with my ideas everything
you're saying is playing in one ear and
out the other is so dumb please don't
bring her there dummy
Bravo Kylie truly Bravo someone get this
girl nemi oh and if you thought Kendall
and Kylie's mom Kris Jenner were spared
from the mockery think again those are
key chains your cute jeans those are
mine no oh I thought you said your cute
jeans did yeah they recreated that
moment - those are key chains your cute
jeans those are mine no oh I thought you
said your cute jeans dude those are my
jeans No
then when you say cute jeans no but
seriously
Kylie is
Jeanne's anyway while the makeup mogul
has been in quarantine
amid the corona virus pandemic happy
self quarantine she's managed to sneak
in a lot of fun with Stassi the two hung
out at Kylie's brand-new 36 point five
million dollar LA crash pad on Monday
where they lounge by the pool so you're
just going to use all of it all of it
all of it you're just going to use all
of it for this video at least raise them
on me and twerked venom to Tigers they
snag it yeah twerked what's happening
Carol basket um who else is seriously
impressed most likely to win a twerk
contest honestly people don't notice
about me though but it moves kylie
jenner reality star entrepreneur
billionaire twerking queen Tik Tok
legend
those are keychains your cute jeans
those are mine no of course this isn't
the first time Kylie playfully paid
tribute to her fam
tick-tock so are we cool like are we in
agreement Kylie and Kris recently
blessed us by recreating an iconic scene
between her big sis courts and courts
acts Scott Disick
abcdefg I actually know what the heck is
ABCD efg me in case you don't remember
the infamous one-liner let's back it up
this is chill time you work for me right
now the og moment went down when Kourt
and Scott were arguing and court decided
to enter the convo with the alphabet so
are we cool like are we in agreement
ABCD efg I have to know what the heck is
ABCD efg me it's just a phrase I like to
use that means not a real friend the
conversation is over
yeah Kylie and Kris totally killed it I
don't know if it would have come so
my mother wasn't who she is are we cool
like are we in agreement
abcdefg I actually know what the heck is
ABCD efg me it's just a phrase I like to
use that means not a real friend the
conversation is over
[Music]